and that lock is open locks like this
are no match for mark tobias
he can easily break in using a widely
available specialty key known as a bump
key
these are the entire tools you need to
open about 95
of the pin tumbler locks in america so
that begs the question
is this smart lock the smarter upgrade
we put that to mark
he's been breaking into lock since he
was 15. in high school the conductor of
the denver symphony got locked in the
dressing room and i figured out how to
get him out and now he consults major
law corporations in finding security
vulnerabilities these companies spend
millions of dollars designing things
that sometimes we figure out how to
break in in 30 seconds so what better
person to test this the nest yale smart
lock and help us decide
is it really smart to install a smart
lock in your home
the pandemic kept a lot of people at
home and interested in making smart
technology upgrades from thermostats and
plugs to lights and speakers
everything is moving towards smart locks
in the industry so that's why we're
testing the nest yale smart lock it
should be four to eight digits long then
press the check to continue it's a
keyless lock that can be opened using a
passcode or when connected to the nest
app and as you see it turns green it can
be unlocked directly from your
smartphone
so why do we choose this lock a few
reasons it's a collaboration of two
major companies yale one of the world's
oldest lock manufacturers and google
nest a key player in home automation
the lock doesn't have built-in wi-fi but
the nest connect system allows the lock
to indirectly connect to wi-fi which the
company says saves battery life
it also has a privacy mode which allows
you to disable the keypad so the lock
cannot be opened with a passcode the
nestio smart lock sells for 279 dollars
with the nest connect system and 249
dollars without the system
mark is testing the lock with the nest
connect
okay this must be
this must be the nest connect we have
not had experience with this lock before
so this will be new for us as well first
he assessed the lock's hardware to
understand how it functions this is the
actual lock it's a
brass finish very neat with a
connectorized cable that goes through
the door
to the back portion
so that the lock can talk to the
electronics
the interesting thing about this lock
that you'll notice there's no lock which
means it's a computer controlled
deadbolt
there's no cylinder there's no bypass
key
some of the smart locks on the market
have a cylinder a bypass key there's
pros and cons and i should also note
that there's a steel insert a little pin
in the middle of this deadbolt that
makes sawing much more difficult mark's
business partner tobias luzmanus a
40-year locksmith completed the
installation process well it seems
pretty easy installation is complete and
your lock is ready to be added to your
nest account
next mark tried the convenience features
on his phone if i hold my finger down on
the app one of them mobile control
you can hear the motor drive in the lock
and now it shows me the status as locked
then mark track the lock's use on the
app this is also going to give me a
history
of every time this lock has been
accessed locked unlocked and it'll tell
me by whom this is a very clever app
especially if you have kids cleaning
staff gardening you send them the code
for two hours one hour whatever the time
block is and then it'll automatically
cancel after that time block please try
again in a moment
finally mark gauge the smart lock
security and how it compared to a
regular lock and key this is a standard
five tumbler cylinder it's fairly old
and it's really common in the united
states honestly it's a good reason to
replace this lock with a smart lock in
less than 10 seconds mark broke the
regular lock open
and that lock is open using a bump key
and that's about normal almost as fast
tobias was able to pick the same lock we
got it open but doing so on a smart lock
isn't as simple for mark regular
locksmith can't unlock this lock he
would have to either drill it or
forcibly remove it still with a smart
lock installed on the door it doesn't
automatically mean the home is secure of
course the real problem is there's glass
everywhere the majority of attacks on
homes are against the doors the strikes
the glass so after trying out the lock
does mark think it's worth the price if
you need the options it's definitely
worth it i would rate it as a five for a
smart lock with the caveat it's not a
high security lock and we did not test
the electronic
security as far as the ability to hack
into it
having said that i would put this on my
condo if i could it looks to me like
it's got all the options the other thing
is you don't need key copies and copies
of keys today can be expensive
so
is it secure it's probably as secure
as any conventional lock
maybe more so because you can't bump
this lock open and you can't pick this
lock open so as far as vulnerabilities
on the mechanical side we don't see any
vulnerabilities
a yale spokesperson said smart locks do
offer an added layer of security over
strictly mechanical locks
she added the nest yale lock is
compatible with most doors with a single
cylinder deadbolt and that the nest yale
lock is compatible with most of the
residential market you need to put the
cover back
on like that
i'll put the cover on
[Music]